i love you dad but we don't even know if  the kid's gonna be a vampire  the cast of the hotel transylvania films  are incredible  and so were their voice performances  behind the scenes  operation just keep her distracted and  happy but not too happy  capisce starts now cool i'd be thrilled  if the baby's humanity just like johnny  a thousand leagues beneath the sea this  is  bob say hi bob everybody  just please watch the hair watch the  hair  yeah she's invisible that's why you  can't see her  this is like the nicest hotel i've ever  been to yeah  oh hey how you doing wow is this  behavior getting you sick  too talking  toilet paper well that's a new one  welcome to the bermuda triangle where  you'll embark on a monster cruise  of a lifetime